the first new blood pressure guidelines
in 14 years will likely bring a major
change in treatment 11 big medical
groups including the American Heart
Association are now redefining the
danger zone for the top blood pressure
number known as systolic the bar is
lowered from 140 points to 130 the new
guidelines mean an estimated 31 million
more people could be diagnosed with high
blood pressure that would bring the
total to nearly half of American adults
dr. Tara Narula
is a cardiology with northwell health
Nerra good morning good morning charlie
so how did they change what did they
change and secondly what are the
implications so this is a silent deadly
health crisis that we've really been
under treating and what we now have is
over 900 research studies that tell us
that what we previously thought was pre
hypertension or high normal which sounds
ok is really not okay that risk starts
to go up over a high systolic pressure
of 120 so by the time you're at 130 your
risk of cardiovascular events has
doubled so this is really about lowering
the bar raising awareness and early
intervention so what have we done we've
lowered the cutoff from 140 over 90 to
130 over 80 that is Stan now Stage one
hypertension begins at that point we
have several categories normal is still
120 over 80 elevated is when your top
numbers over 120 Stage one between 130
and 140 over 80 to 90 and Stage two over
140 over 90 now within that Stage one
group we were using risk to kind of tell
who's should get medication and who
should have lifestyle recommendations
alone and so if you're at elevated risk
you're going to get lifestyle
recommendations and medication if you're
at a higher risk I'm sorry if you're a
lower risk unit lifestyle
recommendations ver at higher risk
you're going to get medication and
lifestyle that's a lot of numbers to pay
attention to but you keep calling
everybody keeps calling it the silent
killer right what exactly does it do to
your body well what it is doing is
eventually it's increasing the pressure
in the blood vessels that supply blood
to all the organs of the body so you're
slowly and silently damaging these
organs over time and it can lead to
heart attack stroke heart failure
peripheral arterial disease like
aneurysms and it really can be a very
insidious disease process and so it's
important to start wrecking
in early they're saying that with these
guidelines it's really going to affect a
lot of individuals under the age of 45
it will triple the number of men under
45 now diagnosed with hypertension and
it will double the number of women which
is a good thing
because we want people to pick this up
early so people the ways we can reduce
our blood pressure so it be healthy so I
mentioned lifestyle and this is kind of
the cornerstone of all treatment even
for those who get medication that means
exercise a heart-healthy diet like the -
diet a diet that's low in salt a diet
that's high in potassium alcohol
consumption no more than two drinks a
day for men no more than one drink a day
for women stress management weight
reduction all these things can lower
your blood pressure by about 4 to 5
points systolic ly that's very
impressive and then of course there is
medication now under the new guidelines
about 50% of Americans are not going to
be meeting that cutoff where they would
be controlled of a 130 over 80 and they
will need to intensify their regimen
with either higher doses or more drugs
all right but it's really only estimated
that about 4 million Americans under
these new recs are going to need
medication thank you thank you thank you